so having been in the States for a few
years now how do you see American movie
critics regarded versus French movie
critics I like the fact that a lot of
American movie critics are not that big
of a deal rather than in Paris it's not
French it's in Paris Paris is a little
town really and the the people who are
in charge of moving producing and movie
movie reviewing are kind of the same
people and they are frequenting each
other and it's it's a small group of
people which is not an insult for me
it's their way of doing it but I think
here in the US there is this tradition
of it's I mean in if France it's more
it's closer to being a friend to people
and being able to interview them rather
than here
there is more of a craft of movie
critics I mean when you look at Roger
Ebert even though Roger Ebert get famous
because of his relentless sometimes
harsh critics but movies are amazing
quicker and moving I think he he managed
to to understand what the craft of
filmmaking was because himself he wrote
a movie for four I think watch a common
he wrote the in the valley of dolls and
so so he had this idea knew what
moviemaking and writing was about so I
think that here in the US it's more of a
profession
whereas in France and Paris it's also
profession but it's also something which
is for them seen by themselves as
as of an artistic format in French movie
critics are seeing them personally
themselves as artists too in a way and
they have to make the critic feel like
it is an artistic form so sometimes this
idea of just I'm gonna write something
as artistical as the movie is against
the critic of itself because it's I
think it's ruining what a movie Creek
should be about which which is stripping
down the filmmaking process and see what
where the choice is made by the director
do you think all potential movie critics
or current movie critics should be
required to at least make one feature
film that's that would be good idea but
I think that would not be possible for a
lot of them but I mean I think that I
mean I there are a lot of them who are
going on a set and and once you are on a
set you understand a bit more what it is
but that's true that when you are not on
the in the chair of the of the director
you cannot feel and you cannot
understand what it is about so yeah if
to say there would be a need for them to
to know what the craft is more about so
yeah maybe going on the set directing
shorts just taking some classes maybe
editing yeah yeah yeah yeah indeed any
group you are truly that's where you are
feeling that you have to make choices
and and filmmaking is about making
choices and cutting a lot of stuff so
yeah I think they will need that
you